good morning John it's easy for us
Americans to get caught in our bubble
especially when things are as weird as
they are right now but the rest of the
world continues to go on and in Brazil
that means the government kind of
totally falling apart in a way that
makes house of cards look poor frankly
boring when I asked about it on Twitter
Brazilians mostly sent me gifs to
explain how they felt but I also got a
message from a diplomat in Brazil who
told me that Brazilians have a saying
Brazil is not for beginners maybe by the
end of this video you will no longer be
a beginner so let's go there Brazil is a
big country 200 million people as big as
the UK France and Germany combined it's
also big enough to fit all of those
countries inside of it three times at
least it's extremely ethnically and
economically diverse with a wide gap
between the richest and the poorest that
economic gap also falls roughly on
racial lines and also on political lines
with wealthy white people mostly in big
cities being mostly conservative and
poor people of native or African descent
being more liberal Brazil has a diverse
economy they're the ninth largest
producer of oil the second largest
producer of beef the third largest
producer of iron ore and they have the
world's seventh largest economy in 1964
to 1985 they were ruled by a military
dictatorship and in a stunning turn of
events
that military dictatorship had a lot of
bribery and corruption in it but in an
actual not sarcastic stunning turn of
events Brazil managed to transfer from
that military dictatorship to a
democracy with relative ease
and like sort of slowly and without very
much violence so it's worth remembering
throughout this entire process that
though Brazil seems very mature
economically and politically its
government is only 30 years old it's new
and they haven't been doing it for very
long it's pretty remarkable it was
plenty of economic and political badness
in the 1980s and 90s but thanks to a lot
of hard work and China's insatiable
appetite for iron ore and hamburgers ill
manage to get its economy on track and
it's become one of the great success
stories of the developing world until
the last couple of years so remember how
bribery and corruption were really
rampant in the old military dictatorship
well that's a difficult thing to take
out of the culture of both companies and
the government and it has not been
removed in Brazil but over the last
thirty years Brazil has become more
democratically mature and somewhat
unusually for Latin America it has a
really strong independent judiciary and
a really strong independent police force
so the rock of Brazil's culture of
bribery and corruption has come up
against the hard place of its strong
independent judiciary and something had
to break and it has before we get there
let's talk about Lula Luiz Inacio Lula
da Silva was in the 80s a revolutionary
socialist who mostly worked against the
military dictatorship as a union
organizer after the dictatorship
transition to democracy in a very weird
cool long story that I don't have time
to tell you Lula emerged as a strong
political figure and the head of the
newly formed Workers Party and the
workers party wasn't able to gain much
national traction until Lula became what
some Brazilians called Lula light still
Lula still for the people still from the
poorest part of the country still
representative of that soul of Brazil
and also willing to work inside of the
system also willing to help out big
corporations who are a big part of
Brazil's economy and how Brazil works
stir running and losing three times Lula
was elected in 2003 and remained
president until 2011 during which time
he presided over some truly remarkable
achievements including an extremely
successful social program that basically
paid poor families to send their
children to school program that's
credited with helping lift tens of
millions of Brazilians out of poverty
Lula left office with an unprecedented
eighty percent approval rating his chief
of staff an economist who was once a
guerilla fighter against the military
dictatorship and was captured by them
and tortured amazing life this woman has
had and continues to have was elected
pretty much as his successor because he
couldn't run for a third term now Lula
was almost never blamed free in 2005 his
government was involved in a scandal
which saw members of Congress being paid
$12,000 a month to vote the way that
Lula wanted them to vote but Lula was
never directly implicated in the scandal
though several members of his government
resigned and Brazil it has become so
common for huge scandals to fizzle out
without anybody getting in trouble that
they have a phrase for it they call it
ending in pizza and I'm not saying some
Portuguese word that sounds like pizza
I'm saying pizza well the days of things
ending in pizza appear to be over for a
bunch of different reasons first because
of the massive scale of the scandal and
yes we're finally going to get there
Petrobras
is Brazil's only oil company it's
majority owned by the government and
entirely controlled by the government
it's brazil's largest company one of the
world's largest companies it's
responsible for 10 percent of Brazil's
GDP and a lot of its governments revenue
and it spends as you might expect a lot
of money on construction contracts
and it's maybe always kind of in the
case that high up Petrobras employees
and the government officials who
appointed them because remember
Petrobras is controlled by the Brazilian
government would give contracts to
construction companies that overcharge
the government massively and the CEO of
the construction company would pocket
some of the difference and some of the
difference would come back to the
politicians and the employees who you
know help get them that contract it's a
very common corruption thing we have it
here in the US we call it graft it's
basically just a company bribing a
politician for a lucrative contract says
Petrobras grew under Lula thanks mostly
to the price of oil getting really high
the amount getting kicked back grew in
is well - truly massive massive
proportions it's the largest corruption
scandal in the history of any democracy
on earth billions of dollars one guy has
offered because you know he's scared to
give all of the money that he took in
bribes back to the Brazilian government
that amount of money is a hundred
million dollars one guy many people are
going to jail this is not ending in pits
around a hundred of Brazil's current
members of Congress almost a fifth of
the entire body of Congress is under
investigation right now no political
party is blamed free but the Workers
Party which was in charge at the time
and also supposed to be the party
against this kind of corruption is
catching most of the flat it's more than
just the scale it's also just awful
timing people are poised to dislike the
government right now because Brazil is
in the middle of a giant recession a
scandal has resulted in lots of lost
jobs the Zika virus epidemic is hurting
tourism Chinese retraction is terrible
for Brazil massive trickle-down loans to
large corporations didn't spur economic
growth and if you've been to a gas
station recently you know that oil is
not the profit Center it once was always
difficult for politicians and citizens
Brazil has had to implement austerity
measures to get its budget in line with
its revenue but it's more than just the
scale and the awful timing Brazil also
really mostly doesn't like the current
president they just don't like her
two-thirds of the country according to a
recent poll want her to be impeached but
it's more than just the scale in the
economy and the president that nobody
likes it's also judge Moro a guy who has
taken lessons from the 90s campaign and
Italy to take down the Mafia a guy who
is willing to make deals with criminals
if it means uncovering more the scandal
a guy who
doesn't mind bending the rules if it
means getting support from the public
and a guy who doesn't seem to mind being
deified and exalted by a lot of the
Brazilian public searching for some non
political person to put their faith and
Brazilians have taken a lot of the love
that they lost for Lula and put it into
judge Morra
he says he has no interest in politics
but he doesn't really seem to be acting
that way and if reshef is impeached and
there are two current hearings trying to
impeach her a lot of people would like
judge Moro to run but it's more than
just the scale in the economy and the
president - the charismatic judge who
takes no prisoners or rather takes lots
of prisoners it's also the deep kind of
ugly partisan divide in Brazil no one
knows how involved Rousseff and Lula
were in the Petrobras scandal or if they
were involved at all but it doesn't seem
like anybody's waiting for due process
to make their judgments in a story that
might feel pretty familiar to people in
America social media has hyperpolarized
Brazil people in Brazil spent a lot of
time on social media and their filter
bubbles are just as strong as ours
people tend to hear and thus think just
the worst things about their opposition
and everyone's cynicism about everyone
else which I had made is kind of
justified results and lack of skepticism
about negative stories of the opposition
and I'm not saying this is a unique
problem to Brazil but like when judge
Morrow released a recorded telephone
conversation in which Rousseff appeared
to be telling Lula how she would protect
him from prosecution a lot of people
thought how could anyone still be
supporting these people they are so
obviously corrupt but a lot of other
people thought why is a judge taking
this seemingly political action in
making this recording public a mere
three hours after it was recorded
without due process Lula and Rousseff
say there's just 100% partisan attacks
trying to take them down and have the
opposition parties gain political power
the opposition says that it's a hundred
percent just them trying to get to the
bottom of the stand even a cursory
inspection though shows that it is
definitely both of those things in
response to her plummeting approval
ratings and multiple impeachment
hearings and also possibly to protect
him from prosecution recesses brought
Lula on as her chief of staff and if
that seems fishy it's because it is also
the more conservative parties some of
them fed by classism and racism are
definitely using this as a political
opportunity to gain power meanwhile on
the Left a lot of people are seeing the
Workers Party is way too centrist and
obviously corrupt and are running away
from them toward the left
and that's just creating a deeper
partisan divide inside of the country
but every major party is involved five
of the people on rosettes impeachment
committee are under investigation
themselves many of the most respected
leaders in the country are not going to
make it out of this unscathed which
means that it's gonna be hard for Brazil
to lead its way out of this problem but
it isn't just the bribery that's the
problem
Paulo Maloof who it literally can't
leave Raziel because he's wanted by
Interpol and for reelection and one with
a campaign slogan I steal but I deliver
Lula on the other hand has had his own
quote from 1988 thrown back at him on
every social media platform on the
Internet in Brazil when a poor man
steals he goes to jail when a rich man
steals he becomes a minister
many Brazilians now see this as Lula
predicting his own future now this is
all bad in the near term for Brazil but
I think it's good for Brazil in the long
term because it shows that being a
crooked politician is not worth it as
for what happens tomorrow and the next
day nobody knows it's a bad situation
and Brazilians on the whole are very
cynical about the government but they're
also very pragmatic while passions can
certainly run high in individuals
there's an overall culture of peaceful
evolution rather than violent revolution
and very few people seem at all
interested in giving that up which is
great news John I'll see you on Tuesday
thank you to diplomat Rafael Prince and
journalist and author Alex Quadros for
all of your help Alex's book Brazilian
airs will be out in July and thank you
as well to all of the members of the
Brazilian nerdfighter Facebook group
thanks for helping me out getting me
straight